all right yo man you already know let's
get to it baby yeah
uh-huh
what are we doing here we go
it's mr roger
[Music]
brad what up though
see you over there bossy
uh-huh
ryder
ruger
40
yo
y'all thought they left us off versus
[ __ ] you ordered y'all funeral hearses
[ __ ] you and they said we wouldn't make
it [ __ ] you roger yo
i used to want to stick your man up now
you might see me in the lam truck banned
up and i'm with your baby mother and
what what [ __ ] want to call the cops
on ruger
like i won't hide a block full of
shooters run rookie run get hit in your
back my little [ __ ] will smoke you
turn you into a pack my man got tired of
his honda turn it into a back now he
rolling like a 60 crep ain't nobody give
me [ __ ] got it out the mud i'm self-paid
[ __ ] really by myself boy i'm self-made
[ __ ] you know i talk to talk you know i
walk the walk got money in a few towns
but i'm from new york mix in my closet
with drawers and deposits trying to tell
me that he against her i'm like stop it
stop it we did a background check he
might be wearing the wire he needed pat
down next man stop playing boy you
better be worried i got some young
[ __ ] shooting better than curry
before rap was on a whole different zone
[ __ ] i ran a crack operation with three
phones [ __ ] you want some lame [ __ ] i
walk a million dollar meetings with a
white tee on all my damn [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
trying to elevate you [ __ ] on some
lame [ __ ]
you'll kill your own brother but
extremely gang [ __ ] drove dropped
through the block it got excited excited
talking records on the phone it got him
indicted you ain't talking big money you
gotta be quiet quiet i don't eat with
hating [ __ ] that's not in my diet
we went from the roaches and the rats
[ __ ] so we were porsches all in black
all in black now we got all the horses
on our back on our back watch how you
approach me boy i'm strapped okay
announce your fan on the spot on the
spot unless you're getting blamed on a
spot
mr ruger
mr ruger
signing off
the head shooter
i strap up and lay the truck around the
river and ain't getting back up you have
to walk around them right i back up then
pack up whoever talk about it
mercedes-benz messed up this ain't the
dawn the album right doubt them i break
the glasses on the rim it's hard for you
to see i break the glasses on you then
the illness on the court i'm back at it
again [ __ ] on these adults i'm nasty
with depends ben would you never be
ethely effortless all throughout my
legacy y'all cannot contend with me
check the list let me see call it like a
referee i'm catching bodies left and
right y'all getting the pepper seeds
check my record please all i spit is
ether and y'all ain't even want it but
i'm on it like i'm featured right you
talking from the bleachers i walk you
out your sneakers these shells make them
run i'm performing my adidas
you're origin lyrical i want to hear you
talk how you talking your interviews
tall as the review go come and talk to
the general i talk to everybody like i'm
talking in general it's critical and
pitiful the aura is invisible while here
doing what i want to do while y'all be
pretending to right get with who i send
you to the lord you surrender to i'm
spiritual i talk but keep it short as an
interlude
so it's confusing i don't even know if
the fans want new [ __ ] they stuck on my
ocean pay me your recruitment i'll let
you down a whole hit i would've let you
use this but they don't know i wrote
this go drift listen fam i ain't doing a
joke with as you versus these
timberlands and still
[ __ ] running on my zone since 06. this
is really zone 6 this is really zone
stitches
i'm spinning on the whole clip jazzy
full of balls spitting like the old kiss
[ __ ]
i scared rap crowds if these heavy bars
this is clear path fell i'm ahead of
y'all i make my peers back down with
these metaphors right then i break them
all down with the wrecking ball right i
check em all then i check em all who
checkin for you on this checkerboard and
what we checkin for right your girl
ready we know what she ready i hit her
for the becky she be at my beck and
chords come and hold me anytime we ever
talk i tell her that i'm ot she want me
to teleport
that's cause i'm better than everybody
taking all bets i'm betting with
everybody [ __ ] you just a regular
anybody i catch a lick it won't be henny
for anybody
[Music]
wait wait wait i like this energy we on
but we're gonna switch
i'm headed nowhere fast running in place
gunning on my waist it's that old dmx
flow one of the greats and what they
want from a [ __ ] i come and replace
they must be talking about the bank if
they want me to chase sucker free state
will later make the night feel bloody
the place i black out like mama spent
the light bill money signed and sealed
get it mean i write real ugly i sold
fake pills i really had a night quit
funny i was fresh y'all street to the
wreck yard still doing dip sets trying
to keep my reps hard newspaper under my
clothes a fake chest guard so just like
kev i had a bootleg kevlar [ __ ] i make
your yes men suffer everybody getting
front page freshman cover sporty when
you ain't you know like a best friend
lover gs9 seeing your mama your head
gets smothered paused you know we had
them everyday grams we stayed on them
hills mary j dance off my resume the
bands i made in chevrolet vans i get can
hit my books like we better spade's hand
but this is upstage we set up your stage
plan make your show to say boo like
elements made fans load the clip too
much that the weapons stay crammed
lebron status should have never let that
spaceship get a bullets room to breathe
something biggie taught me you gonna
need a room to breathe with machines in
the story though midlife crisis i hit
you with saying 40.
weapon to get you to something shorty
right speaking of shorty i know my
daughter is watching real estate of mine
and i'm not buying out property i live
by apollo but not denying apologies now
every little thing gets you buck dollar
tree
no chef but i need a baker i toast we
gon hold zach down like we stretching
slater giving vacates you need to pay
something
[Music]
yo man
40 cal j.r
different let's go man bootleg cap show
blackhead podcast